[contemplative music]
What would it take
to build a more perfect world?
With nations at peace.
A healthier planet
for our children.
And prosperity for all.
What knowledge will we need?
What values will unite us?
Who will lead the way?
Today, humanity
is faced with challenges
that are growing increasingly
serious and complex.
Climate change
and environmental degradation.
Political extremism and war.
Economic development
and disparity.
Migration and global health.
The hope of a prosperous future
will require
commitment, passion
and planning.
A multidisciplinary approach
to problem solving.
A willingness
to consider diverse viewpoints.
And an abiding belief
in our ability to find answers
together.
With wisdom, facts, insight
and courage.
For more than 300 years,
Yale has advanced humanity's
understanding of complex
global issues
and educated leaders
committed to addressing them.
By establishing the
Yale Jackson
School of Global Affairs,
we further
underscore our commitment
to cultivate
an intimate community
of outstanding faculty,
seasoned practitioners
and students who will study
and develop policy
to address
the challenges of today
and the opportunities
of tomorrow.
To advance Yale's mission
with outstanding research
and scholarship, education
and practice.
To prepare students
for leadership
and service on the global stage.
To be a champion for light
and truth in the world.
To all of you who have helped
make the Yale Jackson
School of Global Affairs
possible— thank you.
And to those who will lead
on behalf of humanity,
the future belongs to you.